the war in ukraine has caused widespread
devastation once thriving cities have
been reduced to ruins
manuel cha's met residents near kiev who
are trying to rebuild their homes and
lives
many are struggling to repair the damage
caused by russian attacks
we met katya by chance on the site of
the media's main road we were filming
the destruction caused when a missile
hit her building she was keen to show us
inside
back in march when russian troops were
advancing on kiev fierce fighting took
place in the area with hundreds of homes
made inhabitable
everything is falling apart like here
and here
the water came as you can see is
dripping on the windows here
it's the same in the room
everything is destroyed
nothing left
there are no windows here
katja says local authorities assess the
damage not long after the strike but she
hasn't received any help since then
i paid for the repairs myself i used all
the money i had and i installed new
windows to keep the crows and the
sparrows from coming inside
katya is doing what repairs he can but
some require qualified personnel
we can fix the windows ourselves but we
need specialists for the roof
you need to have special skills for that
pensioners
old women and men who live here they
can't do it by themselves
although she wasn't home at the time of
the attack
katya is still reeling from the shock of
the missile strike
i just can't imagine how such a thing
could happen
that the russians
our so-called brothers
could launch a war on us
with so much destruction
ukrainians will never forgive that
the local authorities do what they can
but they too are overwhelmed
there are two options
either people wait for payments from the
regional or state government or we at
the local level can also help
but we always had a problem finding
people for such work and now even more
so given the number of people who went
abroad
the city councilor says temporary
housing is planned for the colder months
but many vulnerable people in katja's
situation don't want to leave their
homes no matter how damaged they are
no i will stay here because we need to
fix everything
look as you can see i'm trying with our
roof while it's still summertime
because afterwards the rainy season will
come
for now the russian troops may have left
the kiev area but the damage they've
inflicted on civilian infrastructure
will take months if not years to be
repaired
let's take a closer look at the scale of
the destruction in ukraine now rush the
russian invasion uh of ukraine it's
destroyed over 100 hospitals damage to
civilian infrastructure is running at an
estimated 4.5 billion euros every week
thousands of kilometers of roads have
been wrecked hundreds of bridges have
been blown up ukrainian officials have
put the total economic losses from the
war at over 500 billion euros rebuilding
the country will be an enormous task
international leaders are gathering for
a two-day conference in switzerland to
discuss raising funds for the
reconstruction effort
dw's brussels bureau chief alexander
fannahman joins us now from lugano in
switzerland to talk more about this
alexandra the war is still raging with
no war with no end in sight isn't it too
early to talk about reconstruction
well it is not too early according to
the ukrainian authorities and to the
officials that are going to come
together here in lugano
they are saying now it's the time to
start working on a reconstruction plan
for ukraine and they're already pointing
to what we just saw in the report to
people they're already starting to
rebuild their homes the ukrainian
president is expected to address the
meeting and he has already made clear
that his goal is not only to restore
what was destroyed he wants to create a
new basis for ukraine modern safe
barrier-free and he's speaking about
huge investments that are needed
including new technologies including
investments in climate and digital so
this is something that they are going to
discuss here in lugano
okay the outcome of the war is still
unclear at that at this point given that
what can we expect from this conference
well we expect the ukrainian government
to present a national plan how to
implement all of that that we've just
been speaking about
the prime minister of ukraine is here
five of his ministers they are going to
come together with leaders from dozens
of countries and international
institutions of course believing that
this war will be over one day and it
will be then ready to rebuild their
country ozola fonder lion the european
commission president is also going to be
here attend this meeting and he is
expected to promise ukraine that europe
will be with them every step of their
way and she's also expected to
present a platform to coordinate eu
donations uh to mobilize what could
amount to more than 500 billion of euros
alexander thank you very much that was
our brussels bureau chief alexander fun
naman